formé à l'olympique lyonnais où il
disputera deux cent soixante matchs dans
les années 80 passé par saint-etienne
marseille et paris laurent fournier 54
ans est aujourd'hui le nouvel entraîneur
de l'as poissy conférence de presse ce
jeudi matin pour le nouvel homme fort du
football qui siècle c'est toujours
valorisant d'être sur un terrain de
de faire partager ce que c'est ce qui
nous a permis de gagner pas mal de
titres
de faire comprendre aux jeunes que
de travailler à l'extérieur c'est
toujours mieux que de travailler à
l'intérieur et que le sport et ben c'est
le foot c'est populaire c'est ça permet
d'aller de s'extérioriser d'être bien
dans sa peau son ambition la montée
d'ici deux ans la haye ce poids si
actuellement national de la 4e division
française et qui vient de terminer cette
saison à la 9e place
je pense que on a effectivement d'un
côté la difficulté d'être du monde
amateur mais c'est un monde formidable
et d'un autre côté des anciens pros qui
sont fédéraux donc c'est de retrouver
alchimie entre ces jeunes donc ces
jeunes issus de la fois ci de les faire
monter en nationale 2 et ses anciens de
les entourer
je pense que c'est très important
aujourd'hui pour réussir notre projet le
psg le red star créteil laurent fourni
retrouve donc une place sur le banc
d'une équipe francilienne puis de trois
ans après avoir quitté son dernier poste
d'entraîneur il reprend du service et ne
devrait pas déroger à sa réputation d'
homme combatif et possédant un certain
franc-parler
j'ai pas trouvé que c'était incohérent
cette année j'ai juste trouvé qu'ils
avaient les résultats étaient en
dents-de-scie donc peut-être problème
de mental mais on l'a vu le mental n'y a
pas que l' exploit si certaines équipes
comme le paris saint germain ont perdu
contre manchester alors qu'ils avaient
mené 2 0 et là aussi c'est pas un
problème de qualité
c'est juste un problème de d'exigence et
quand on est exigeant je crois qu'on
arrive à faire pas mal de choses